foreign
[Music]
we have gathered a lot of news to share
with you we talk about the Mandalorian
Elita battle Angel 2 and Spider-Man
across the spider-verse in addition you
can learn about all the plans that the
new DC bosses James Gunn and Peter
saffron have come up with in our huge
news on DC let us tell you this much not
all characters from the dceu will have
their place in the future we hope you
enjoy our video
when Elita battle Angel was released in
2019 the movie was able to throw
countless fans however a sequel was not
set in stone so it did come as a
surprise what producer John Landau had
to announce in the course of a deadline
interview according to Landau who is in
charge of production for both the
upcoming Avatar the way of water and
Elita battle Angel he would be very
pleased to produce a sequel he has
already spoken with director Robert
Rodriguez about it Landau hopes to see
his words turned into action in the near
future nevertheless he refused to give
the whole thing a concrete time stamp as
this could be used against him so it
doesn't sound like a hundred percent
confirmation of the sequel but fans can
still be optimistic it should be
interesting to see how high the
production costs will be this time after
all the original film cost nearly 200
million US Dollars and only grossed
twice as much at the box office which is
not all that much in comparison in
return however they have created a fan
favorite that could easily be built upon
as the manga certainly provide plenty of
material stay tuned for more news on
Alita battle angel 2.
Disney plus currently offers more Star
Wars projects than ever including the
book of Boba Fett Andor and Obi-Wan
Kenobi the kickoff for today's series
abundance however came from another
series and that was the Mandalorian
after the start of season 1 in 2019 a
large fan base formed around the series
especially the cute baby Yoda became
famous beyond the limits of Star Wars
fans now there has already been a
two-year break since season 2 which was
caused in part by pandemic related
restrictions on production apparently
the waiting time is now to be extended a
little longer according to a League
season 3 was originally supposed to be
released in February Disney obviously
sees that differently and so we will
have to remain patient until March the
season like of Eight Episodes will not
change for the time being and the people
responsible for the first two seasons
will also be back for the most part on
the acting side there are also plenty of
familiar faces to be spotted including
Pedro Pascal as the Mandalorian Katie
Sackhoff is Bo Katan Giancarlo Esposito
as MAF Gideon Carl Weathers as green
karga and Emily swallow as the armor
also confirmed our newcomers Christopher
Lloyd made World Famous by Back to the
Future and The Goldberg's actor Tim
Meadows enrolls not yet known the first
trailer was released in mid-september a
selected audience was recently able to
see new footage at this year's Comic-Con
in Brazil however the general public
will probably have to wait a little
longer the story in season 3 will be
about dinjar's journey to Mandalore
after making a fatal mistake he must
free himself from his guilt in order to
become an honorable part of the
mandalorians again we hope to see a new
trailer soon the Mandalorian season 3
will be released on March 1st 2023 as
usual on Disney Plus
this week we've got another wave of
announcements from Warner Brothers as
The Hollywood Reporter exclusively
claims DC is facing the biggest
reorganization in years and many movies
are affected by the restructuring the
first piece of news concerns the planned
third movie in the Wonder Woman
franchise although leading actress Gal
Gadot still made a promo for Wonder
Woman on Twitter this week the movie is
now completely put on hold the reason is
a creative disagreement between director
Patty Jenkins and DC Studios heads James
Gunn and Peter Safran jenkins's worked
out plan no longer fits the current
vision of saffron and Gunn and thus the
film has been scrapped obviously also to
the surprise of gal Gad Patty Jenkins
had been drafting the script since 2019
even before the release of Wonder Woman
1984 and she also said that the story
arc had always been designed for three
separate films when an official
confirmation for the third part followed
two days after the theatrical release of
Wonder Woman 1984 barely anyone actually
had doubts about the completion of the
film although neither the reviews nor
the box office takings were worth
the second piece of news concerns Man of
Steel 2 which has been repeatedly teased
in recent weeks and boosted by Henry
cavill's appearance and Black Adam 2 was
considered as good as certain however as
early as November occasional rumors
surfaced that the likelihood of it
happening was not as high as it was
believed to be nevertheless even Dwayne
Johnson did not retired of emphasizing
his Merit in the return of Henry Cavill
until recently saffron and Gunn seemed
to have other plans in their new
position as DC bosses however as Man of
Steel 2 is officially no longer on the
agenda that's because the Snyder verse
and all of the superheroes involved are
to be removed to create a clear cut
between the old and nude dceu the DC
heads are now taking all sorts of steps
to report back to Warner Brothers
Discovery head David zazlab next week
and present their plans for the universe
still the decision not to let Henry
Cavill return after all is likely to
cause great frustration among fans after
all Campbell is considered a true fan
favorite things are not looking good for
the sequel to Black Adam at the moment
either as the box office results do not
reflect the expected up those
responsible at all so far the film has
grossed just under 390 million on a
production budget of up to 230 million
Which is far from a success according to
a Variety article from last week Black
Adam would need to bring in about 600
million US dollars to cover all costs
including marketing and turn a profit at
the moment however it doesn't look like
that's going to happen even though
Dwayne Johnson published his own figures
on Twitter on Wednesday claiming the
opposite so the odds of a sequel are low
for Black Adam as well next would like
to talk about the Aquaman franchise the
second part will be released on December
25th 2023 but what will happen after
that in all likelihood the Aquaman
franchise will not survive the
restructuring either so after Aquaman
and the lost kingdom it will probably
all be over for Jason momoa's character
according to current reports however the
actor himself will not be written off
but rather be given a new role in DC's
future Momoa is reportedly set to play
the alien Bounty Hunter Lobo who made
his first appearance in the Omega men
comics in 1983. in the 2018 series
Krypton which is a prequel to Superman
Lobo was already embodied by Emmett J
Scanlon in fact even back then there
were people who envisioned Jason Momoa
much more suited for the role finally in
addition to all the surprise decisions
which surely not everyone will be
pleased with we would like to announce
one piece of positive news the Batman
franchise is accept from the
restructuring so Matt Reeves is still
working on the Batman too and the
further expansion of the film series
should also move forward so what do you
think of all these announcements and are
you able to understand why gun and
saffron want to make a cut in order to
completely reboot the dceu feel free to
let us know your opinion in the comments
only recently did Phil Lord surprise us
in an interview with the statement that
the upcoming Spider-Man across the
spider-verse will feature not one but
six animation Styles depending on the
scene these are to be adapted to the
plot and raise the visuals to a new
level this week we have more news about
the upcoming Multiverse movie and the
form of new images you can see the main
character miles who for once is not in
his superhero outfit but in everyday
clothes in a crowd of people a different
image shows miles and Gwen Stacy from
behind in the background you can see the
scenery of New York City and according
to the photo and Gwen's ponytail the two
are sitting upside down thanks to their
spider powers in addition the
responsible parties have provided a date
for the first trailer which is supposed
to be released on December 13 2022
leaked merchandise for the film also
gives us some New Impressions the images
show miles in a Black and White costume
reminiscent of the Noir Spider-Man as
well as Spider Gwen and Spider-Man 2099
now it is already clear that the
variations of Spider-Man will be even
greater than before after some memorable
appearances in the first part the
Multiverse will thus open up a bit more
in terms of numbers this means that
almost 240 characters will appear in the
sequel while in 2018 there were only 40
on June 2nd 2023 the time will finally
come and we will be able to see
Spider-Man across the spider-verse in
theaters we are definitely excited for
the trailer in the coming week
Hollywood was shocked when Warner
Brothers Discovery under the leadership
of its new CEO announced that the two
movies Batgirl and Scooby-Doo would
never see the light of day despite their
completion the reason given was the
focus on qualitatively larger and better
known projects for many it was clear
that it will certainly not stop at the
two films and so only a few believe that
DC's Blue Beetle would ever run in
theaters now via Twitter DC decided to
end the mystery as the responsible
parties published a first poster and
thus a definite proof that the film will
be released much to the Delight of many
fans the studio also directly provides a
date for the theatrical release which is
August 18 2023. you can't really guess
much from the new poster so it's still
not clear what the plot will be like the
superhero has a long history in DC
Comics and first appeared in mystery man
Comics number one 1939 the beetle-like
main character has powers such as
superhuman strength the absorption of
energy a shield against toxic
environmental influences and of course
flying Beetle will also be DC's first
film centered around a Latin American
superhero now that the promotional face
has started we are looking forward to
more news about Blue Beetle soon which
will be out on August 18th 2023.
that was this week's news we'll see you
again next Saturday with the latest news
about Hollywood and the world of films
in the meantime if you want to see more
check out the new amazing trailers for
Gen B and the last of us until then we
wish you lots of fun with our video
content here on our Channel thanks for
watching
laughs
[Music]